the Chevelle Pakistan more than a
million Afghan refugees have crowded
into the city close to the Afghan border
many of them have fled the war plaguing
their country for decades
nasty lob a table is one of them he was
born in Pakistan and has lived in this
camp his whole life his University
educated and used to work as a teacher
Nasir last five children are all in
school being forced to leave is the last
thing he wants my parents and
grandparents are buried here and I can
visit their graves whenever I want my
friends from school in university are
all here my life is here and I wonder
how can I just leave everything in a few
months if the government just allowed us
to stay to continue our jobs we could
live in peace there are nearly
one-and-a-half million registered Afghan
refugees in Pakistan and many more
living here illegally all of them have
been told they have to leave the country
by March 31st previously the government
had assured their legal status for at
least a year
this most recent deadline has come amid
increasingly hostile relations between
Kabul and Islamabad Pakistan says the
presence of Afghan refugees is not only
a drain on resources but is also a way
for terrorists to infiltrate the country
from across the border there are fans
who are living as aliens here in our
country about 30% of them in the Cape's
70% of them are outside they are living
in suburbs of major cities and townships
there is no mechanism through which we
should be able to check as to who is who
amongst them and they are aliens they
have no status no fish no nothing so we
will start with them their number is
something like point 4 million right I
will push them out and whatever methods
could we use we will use that
Afghanistan has recently seen a wave of
deadly attacks eid agencies fear for the
safety of those who return UN officials
also say the repatriation of so many
refugees is an unrealistic task to
undertake by this latest deadline
they're hoping talks with the government
may help them by time any large-scale
returns from Pakistan or elsewhere will
have significant humanitarian
impact we there are economic challenges
in some places there are line order
situation which is not satisfactory and
there are issues like health education
and livelihood challenges in Afghanistan
and so these are the challenges which
needs to be addressed and the
international community should provide
targeted development assistance in a
one-cent some political commentators
suggest that holding the fate of
refugees in the balance is one of
Pakistan's bargaining chips when dealing
with diplomatic pressure and while many
refugees like Nasir la fear they are
being used as political pawns they have
no choice but to accept their life in
limbo as another deadline ticks down